hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
i've been investing in properties now
for over a decade
and i seem to spend most of my time
answering people's questions
about property on youtube these days so
this is q
and a sunday and i'm going to be
answering last
week's questions and there's some really
juicy questions
i'm going to be answering today however
this is about you right now so what i
want you to do is i want you to comment
your questions your property investment
questions
in the comment box below no question is
too dumb or silly
and no question is too complex because
i've been doing this a long time so
comment below next sunday i'm going to
answer your questions
and while i'm answering other people's
questions maybe you might think
oh my goodness that leads to another
question great comment it below and also
if i answer your question
you got to comment and say thank you as
well okay and if you comment
you need to subscribe turn the
notification bell on
because otherwise i might be answering
your question next week and you don't
even know because you didn't subscribe
you didn't get notified so subscribe
notify also smash the like button i want
to see that little like symbol you need
to see that turn blue
whilst watching the video it will give
you more power and success in your life
if you see the thumb below so
press that smash that like button right
now and let's get right to this so
darius says
i have a question i'm purchasing a
property however i have to wait for the
landlord to evict the current tenant the
court order was granted before the
lockdown however i have heard that
evictions have been put on hold
does this still apply if the court order
has already been granted
so darius my advice would be i don't
know what you agreed i don't know what
the order was exactly because i haven't
got the solicitor's paperwork in front
of me
i would just go back to the solicitor
and ask them what's what everything's
been held down
because of lockdown so things are
slowing down um so i'm not sure what the
agreement was
it might just be that you need to wait
for the tenants to be evicted which
might take a little bit longer before
you can complete
so read what was written and what was
agreed and ask yourself
a good look with it i hope it's a great
juicy deal and i hope it's worth the
wait
key sg says what was the smallest
startup capital you saw someone use to
start their property portfolio
nothing i've seen people start with
nothing and i started with nothing
i started with paper out money so you
don't need money to get started you just
need to get started and then get the
money and hope the money will come
raise the money but firstly focus on
starting focus on finding the deals
um mahabi says how to find a rent to
rent deal on spare room
if you want to find a rent to rent deal
on spare room i'd find properties that
look suitable for you
and i would message the landlord and ask
them if they're interested in receiving
a guaranteed rent and if they are
explain to them what service you can
offer them bmx vloggers
why do you rent your house an office and
how come you don't use
a supercar or anything like that um
i don't use a supergirl i don't want a
supercar it's really interesting
i just drive and wear and do what i want
rather than thinking about how it's
going to look and what others are going
to think
and i really like my car i drive a nice
car it's a range rover
i like my house the reason i rent it and
don't buy it is because it wouldn't make
commercial sense to buy it
because it's worth several million
pounds
probably around i'd say about three
million pounds my house is worth so if i
was to buy it
the amount of money that would be tied
up i'd be better off using that money
wisely
in investing it commercially and then
with the income rent where i live
it also gives me more flexibility and
freedom so i can move i like to i've
lived in five houses in the last five
years i think
maybe around that so i like to move
around um i hope that helps
and good luck in your journey okay
the minto hi somebody i have a question
regarding deal sourcing
when speaking to investors what
questions would you ask them regarding
what they're looking for
so i'm really glad uh the minto that you
you started with that you said what
questions
should i ask investors that are
interested in working with me because
most people don't get that most people
just try and sell to investors but the
fact that you're saying
what questions should i ask shows that
you're on the right track because you
should be exactly doing that
asking the investors questions asking
them questions like what are you looking
for
like you've said what kind of deals are
you looking for and then if you've got
suitable deals
ask them um ask them if they're in a
position to move
ask them if they've got the funds in
place ask them if they'd be happy to pay
you a sources fee if the deal was right
and then if they say yes yes yes and
you've got a deal that works for them
then ask them how they'd like to pay
that's about as simple as it is
good luck let me know how you get on
okay james
webb says i'm 20 and new to the space
great to see you starting young so much
some of these guys are even younger the
next question i'm going to answer is a
guy who's 16 years old
um your videos are opening my mind up to
the possibilities out there what balance
do you recommend between investing in a
property in your local area
with an emotional gut attachment in my
beijing stoke case
or looking at areas not local to you and
basing decisions purely from data
so james webb you're exactly right the
advantage
to buying outside of your area is that
you take emotions out of it which is a
great thing and you just make decisions
based on formulas not feelings whereas
if it's in your area you get a bit
emotional sentimental
or judgmental oh that was the rough end
of town
yeah but because you live there and
you've judged that area of all life you
don't want to buy a house there
but actually that's much better
investment area so that's the advantage
of buying further away from home another
advantage from buying further away from
home is that you don't get tempted to be
involved in the management side of
things you're going to set it up and
systemize it so it's passive
another advantage is if you're tied to
your home area
you're you're just oh i'm here whereas
if you say i'm going to invest in the
best area
it unties you so you you find areas
solely for their investment area so
i don't invest where i live my only
caveat to that would be
don't invest in somewhere that you don't
know you want to know the area
you want you mentioned gut feeling in
your own area that's a good thing
because sometimes gut feeling can can be
a good thing
and you only have that gut because you
know the area you know what's around
so find a really good area find a
management system
get to know the area and invest there i
mean basing stoke
you can make money in being stoked but
for straight by to let it kind of sucks
just saying it as it is you can make
money anywhere but make sure that you're
using your formulas not your feelings
hope that helps james and good luck
okay next this is the guy who's no he's
not he's not 16.
this goes 13 firstly congratulations for
being a follower and a subscriber of
this youtube channel at such a young age
um honestly if all 13 year olds watch my
youtube channel
the world will be a better place in 10
years time and people will be way more
financially literate so good good job
and and this is abdullah and he says
samuel is it possible to get a lease
option agreement on an unmortgageable
house i'm 13 years old
and i'm trying to learn as much i love
your videos hey thank you so much that
means a lot
you can get a lease option agreement on
an unmortgageable house yes
my but i would question why you would
want to because if it's
unmortgageable house and you have a
lease option agreement on it which says
that you you're gonna buy it say in
seven years time let's say
in seven years time the chances are the
house will still be unmortgageable so
unless it's unmortgageable for a reason
you can fix like for instance if there's
no hot water but you can fix that by
just putting some
hot water in it then it might be good
because you can get a really good deal
and fix it a little bit
i wouldn't spend a load of money on a
lease option agreement house because
until you have the title
deeds you don't want to be investing
loads of money so generally speaking
rule of thumb would be probably not to
get a lease option on an unmonitorable
house but legally you can
hope that helps thanks for watching the
channel hey if you're young and you're
watching the channel you've got to
subscribe too
okay i love i love the young the old
everybody anyone that's got a common
interest
in becoming financially independent and
investing successfully and ethically in
property
is welcome to be a subscriber of my
channel okay
um addie leak says do you think getting
a survey on a property you want to
purchase
is worth the money and if yes what type
of server yes it's absolutely worth
every single penny
i would get an independent building
survey
every time you buy a house especially if
you're buying from auction
um shamaya a chiapong hi samuel i know
you will say my name wrong
did i say it wrong shamaya a chiapong
okay i know you're saying my name wrong
maybe not but people just call me shame
or shammy okay hi shemi what's up
chiapong you are from ghana
see i hope if i got your name right you
got to subscribe right now okay
um if i wanted to be an entrepreneur
property investor for the longest time
have you got any advice for me
my first advice will be don't pre-judge
people and expect them to get your name
wrong
because sometimes that doesn't no i'm
just kidding um give me an example of
what i can start doing and what i should
start doing to earn money
also any advice on the first well-paid
job
if needed i should apply for so shamaya
or shemi or shem or whatever you want to
be called um
if you want to get money and you want to
you got to be valuable to people that's
it
so however young or old you are if you
can
find a way to add value to those two
people find the people that are closest
to you the business people or parents or
friends or
people that have a have businesses and
think how can i add value to these
people and if you don't know
ask them what say what could i do
over the next six months that would add
value to your business and help you get
extra money
and and how can i help be a part of that
it's all about adding value so
um should you get a high paid job if you
want to get a high paid job you've got
you've got to study
to get a hybrid generally not always but
generally you've got to study to get a
traditional high paid job
but to get a high paid income
to get high paid business to get a lot
of cash
you haven't got to get you haven't got
to be well studied and you just got to
be able to add value to people that'll
be my biggest advice
i hope that helps thank you for watching
my channel okay barry s3
says forgive me if this is a stupid
question about deal sourcing when you
sell someone a deal surely you don't
know
you don't show them what the deal is
until they pay you or else they know
what the deal is and don't need
to pay you i don't get it barry what
you're going to do is you're going to
get them to sign an nda a non-disclosure
agreement so they cannot cut you out
next shadow crooks hi samuel i have a
question
what do you do when you reach the end of
a mortgage can you ever can you go ever
refinancing with example numbers please
what if you're in your 60s already and
cannot get another long-term mortgage
um so just because you're in your 60s
does not mean you can't get um
a reasonably long-term mortgage my
intention is to die with mortgages and
to die with debt i don't ever want to
pay them off
um if you get to the end of a mortgage i
would refinance i mean if you can't
refinance you've got a lot of properties
because maybe consider selling
but i if you but selling and then team
up with someone
gets get someone younger this is the
exact opposite of what i did i couldn't
get a mortgage because i was too young
so i got other people
to mortgage host me if i was too old i'd
do the same thing the other way around
there's always a way around but i want
to die with debt
and people think it's strange that i
want to die with debt why wouldn't you
pay off your debts because it's good
debts that's serving me and serving my
business and funding my lifestyle
bad debts is not bad debts is a downward
spiral bad debt's really bad good that's
really good
don pender hi i'm really interested in
hmos just got a few questions can you
list the minimum requirements when
looking to buy our property for a hmo
and when you've got the property ready
to be rented out et cetera eg number of
bathrooms needed minimum size
rooms how far from city centre town etc
thank you um
so basically don't want to know
everything there is to know about hmos
in the q a sunday um
you should probably check out the hmo
boot camp i will leave a
link in the description which takes you
through exactly what hmo is
how to find one how to secure and how to
finance it all the rules
all the areas how to get a management
company how do i manage a hmong yourself
a2z i've done a program called the hma
bootcamp which is an online course
however in in small terms hmos when you
rent a room at room by room
each room needs to be 70 square feet if
there's five or more people generally
speaking you need a license if there's
four or less people you do not need a
license
if it's in an article four area you need
planning or if there's seven or more
people in the property you need planning
if you do not need planning and you do
not need a license i would still
recommend getting fire doors in the
property
make sure the property is rentable make
sure that it's within walking distance
or a short bus journey into a buzzing
city town center
i mean geez like that's that's a few
points about hmos i hope you like it
if you do smash the like don't forget to
subscribe all right next
we've got mike ladd who says samuel this
is my first time commenting i'm glad you
finally called out the woodworks i'm
glad that i managed to tease you to get
into you commenting
massive congrats if you watch my videos
you've not commented now's the time
come on ask me your questions they're
going to be answered next week
how and where in the uk would you invest
30 000 pounds at the moment i'm looking
to buy my first buy to let not sure
whether or not i should hold on for the
moment
due to the current market and the
possibility of house prices dropping in
the near future
keep up the great videos mike ladder
depends on what you want you want cash
flow you want capital appreciation
you've got 30 grand you can set up a
rent to rent business you could put it
into a property do a brr put it in pull
it out
you could just put it in and just wait
and see what happens and wait for
capital appreciation
um i don't know your situation i don't
know where you live i don't know what
you want to get but what i would say is
do something
don't don't don't wait waiters are not
winners
winners are action takers so find what's
the right thing to do for you right now
and then go do it
that'll be my biggest advice okay so so
i might have answered your question
exactly how you wanted it answered but
at least i've told you not to wait
that's not what to do amazing gamer by
the way amazing gamer i really
appreciate you you comment on pretty
much every video
you're usually first to comment as well
so respect he says thanks for the reply
samuel what would you do if you've put
an offer on a property with a decision
to sell to an investor but they ask for
a mortgage in principle
and you don't know if the deal will go
through and you have not sent it off to
an investor
thanks um ayush
um okay timing is everything when you do
this so if you are
finding a deal from an estate agent and
then passing on to an investor before
you put an offer forward to to the
estate agent
you want to get an idea of what they'll
give it to you so you want to do an if
would offer if i was to buy cash
tomorrow what would the lowest accept
and still live with
or if i was to offer 86 what do you
reckon to say i don't think they'd go
for 86. it's gonna need to be it's gonna
need to be closer to 90.
now in your minds you're thinking okay i
know that except 89 then
maybe a little bit less cool then you're
gonna line up an investor
and you're gonna say hey i've got a deal
it's not totally wrapped up yet but i'm
thinking i can get it for 89.
sign an nda here's the house
i've got it for 89. it's worth 105. the
rent's this here's all the research
they've signed an nda so they can't cut
you out and you're gonna say
do you want it if you do i need to wrap
this up quick and i want two grand fifty
three up front
take two grand put that into a little
client account holding count
which you can set up a doddle then wrap
the property up
bring the two together and then upon
completion take that two grand spend
that two grand
or save it keep doing it use that to put
a deposit in your own house
timing is everything i hope that helps
pr max hi samuel great
show thanks for the information you're
welcome i have a question i've got an it
contracting trading company where i get
cash reserves
i want to lend from this company to a
property company i'm the director for
both
do lenders have any reservations if the
deposit comes from another company even
though it's mine
it's still borrowed nope that's fine you
could i know that because i've done that
many times i've
you know i've got different companies
and i move money around and that's
absolutely fine for my lending criteria
i'd probably speak to um an accountant
to make sure you didn't get the most tax
efficiently but lenders might have a
problem with that
i know that speaking from experience
hope that helps good job i'm glad to
hear you've got cash reserves from your
it company we have a lot of students who
are in it that make a lot of money
maxwell says hey samuel when viewing a
property for potential brr
how do you determine what work would
need to be done in the refurbishment
okay again
big question big question i could spend
like i've done courses on this i've done
whole courses on how to price up jobs
how do you know how much work is going
to be done on the refurbishment i mean
i've worked on a building site and i've
kind of
now it's taken years of experience of
training and doing dick deals
i can walk into a house and just know
what needs doing and how much it is
doing for
um i've got even on my um
brr master class i've got a little
spreadsheet which is like a
tells you how much things generally cost
so you can go around a little checklist
um but if you don't really know about
that kind of stuff maybe see if you can
bring a builder
or ask the estate agent says the stage
look you're selling the house how much
do you think it will cost to get this up
scratch
and then put your offer in on the basis
of what they've said
and then when you've put the offer it's
been accepted get a survey and if the
survey doesn't match
what the estate agent said the survey is
saying it's going to be more say look
estate agent you said it'd be 20 grand
the survey is saying 30 grand
i mean to bring my offer down of 10 000
pounds to
for the difference so you don't need to
be an expert you just need to
you just need to know the game that's it
you don't need to be people say oh to be
a property investor you've got to be an
expert oh you've got to be in 20 years
no you don't you just got to know the
game
and lean into other people's expertise
so that's it
all right i hope that helps by the way
if it does drop out drop a like all
right um
i don't know how to pronounce that one
sorry i'm stuck i'm gonna have to go um
i'm just gonna call you sky bocker
because that's that's the second name
uh i'm about to buy my first investment
property buy to let i'm too far to go
and view the property
and that's what cash only no mortgage
can i get someone to have a look and
tell me if it's worth
and what essential research to do for
buy to let i'm very worried if i can't
rent it out
so you can send someone from vuba that's
v i e
w b e r viewer and they'll view it for
you and they'll do a little report on it
that'll cost about 30-40 pounds
um if you're worried about renting it
out everything will rent out at the
right price it will rent out you just
got to figure out what the right price
is
i would suggest going on my property
investors crash course it's a it's a
free course
you can do it online for 195 pounds or
you can come in person for free
um but at the moment you can actually
take advantage of me
right now you can join samuel 365 for
one pound
which is gives you a seven day trial do
the crash course online
and then cancel i hope you don't cancel
but you can do that so you can pretty
much do the crash course online for a
pound
definitely need that foundational
information around buy to let
i hope that helps tia jackson hi samuel
i've started
a co-deal sourcing company followed your
advice from your videos
your advice helped me achieve this so
thank you so much welcome
i need to find off market deals to
vendor to vendor deals
how do i contact a landlord and
negotiate a rental rent or a bmv
purchase without scaring them off
my biggest challenge is negotiating
deals with the vendors i can find good
deals easy
thanks in advance so you've got to
filter them so when you speak to a land
don't book a viewing
and go and be all interested and have a
chat and all that and then put forward
an offer of a rent to rent or then put
forward a below market value cheeky
offer
right up front as soon as you pick up as
soon as they pick up the phone before
you book the view
you're just gonna say something like
this listen i know the house is on the
market for a hundred grand
however just being straight i'm only
likely gonna be able to offer around
about 80 85 grams
is it worth booking a viewing or not
that's it
and then you're gonna get all the
rejection right get go 20 seconds
no how dare you all right let me know if
you change your mind save my number
thank you for your time
20 seconds do that 20 times
you're gonna get one or two that are
interested then go view those
and you've only spent like an hour or
two on the phone
rather than viewing 20 properties
spending weeks doing it
and then getting demoralized after being
told no after four four no's
because you spent so much time i hope
that helps
saraya santos says hi samuel would you
recommend having a property manager who
is not located in the area of your
property
nope your property manager has to be in
the area you don't but they do otherwise
they'll do a bad job they'll take their
after ball you
need a property manager to be in the
area
dale blackwell so i have found
so so i have a property owned by myself
i bought it for 143 000 pounds in 2018
spent 25 000 pounds on it and it's now
worth 225 000 pounds
dude that's amazing you've made a lot of
equity there
so a nice profit of 55 000 pounds i'm
glad you told me because i was trying to
work it on my head
how would you recommend i go about
purchasing a second property bearing in
mind
i have 170 000 pounds worth of equity in
my current house cheers keep up the
great work refinance
you know how to buy a house push the
value up and refinance it you've done
that already so i would say
refinance use that money do the exact
same thing again that is exactly how you
grow and scale a large
healthy property portfolio so keep up
the great work dale let me know if you
need any more help
tyrone saxton says by a great guy tyrone
thank you you comment on all of my
videos i appreciate the support
means a lot brother and i hope to meet
you in person one of the crash courses
once like now is over
last one you have said before something
like for every pound you spend on a
property you want to add three pounds to
the property's value
i was wondering if this is a fact or
just a target for example if i spent
twenty five thousand pound on a house
extension for an extra room and i go and
remortgage or refinance and then in
future take my money out would i
definitely add more than twenty five
thousand
pounds in value to the property that i
invested in the first place
so okay the reason i say when you add a
pound you want to add a three pound
is because i want to get out of people's
minds
see this is what most the banks the
banks
do not want you to invest smart
they can't because they discourage it
you go to the bank and say can i take it
alone to
to buy an investment property they say
it's too risky you say can i take it
alone to buy a wedding and they say no
problem
and the banks encourage you to do house
extensions oh you want to build a
conservatory oh nice oh the kids are
dead oh
lovely his money for it right and most
of the time that's a terrible thing to
do
because you you bought you bought a
conservatory you spent 25 grand
and the value added to the house is
about 20 grand
so you've lost five grand what you wanna
do is you wanna as i say you wanna when
you spend a pound at three pound so you
add an extra room and it costs
and it costs you uh ten grand but then
you add thirty thousand pound bag to the
house
that's the formula so when i say that i
am talking pretty literally not just
target or isn't nice i want to get
people away
from adding value to the house they're
not adding value
they're spending money and and they're
not adding value they're losing money on
it
it's not smart so and if you want oh
yeah but sammy i just want the extension
i just want the conservatory i want it i
know it's not smart but i want it then
rent where you live
like just rent somewhere that you want
paid for out of you being smart
so the formulas in terms of being able
to refinance it the formulas are very
simple and there's only three formulas
when you're doing brr that you need to
contend with there's buying the house
the purchase price then there's the
refurb cost and then there's the gross
development value the end value that's
it
and you need to make sure that when you
buy a house and add value
you need to make sure that the end value
is being pushed up enough that you can
you can have you can refinance and pull
your investment back out
and if you can't pull it and pull it
mostly out this is a numbers game
so tyrone i know you've got a lot of
deals going on you've got hmos and stuff
i'm excited i want to hook up i want i
want i'd love to see some of your houses
um but guys honestly when you're
investing this is this is this is this
is serious this is a
business this is not a oh what do i feel
like
all the tv shows out there that you
watch on tv you know
all these shows it's all about oh this
is nice this is romantic oh look what
they did oh
no this is just a straightforward facts
and numbers game and that's why i run
this youtube channel because i want
people to understand the formulas
i want people to be financially literate
i want people to invest smart so
thank you for being a subscriber of my
channel thank you for watching my videos
i want to see your questions i want to
help you out
comment your questions below if you
enjoy my channel share it with everybody
and the more you comment below the more
this video gets seen
so share it comment like blue thumb turn
the notification bell on because there's
nothing worse than when people comment
on my videos
and then i answer their comments but
they don't ever even see the answer
so subscribe and turn the notification
bell on thank you i'll see you next time